[Aplausos]
él es andy flores andy tiene nueve años
anti padece una condición llamada amelia
de miembros superiores lo que significa
que andy no tiene brazos sin embargo él
juega fútbol monta a caballo es nadador
es estudiante sobresaliente y todo esto
lo hace únicamente con sus pies
cualquiera pensaría que esto es una
desgracia sin embargo para andy esta ha
sido una oportunidad para superarse y ha
sido una oportunidad para demostrar que
a pesar de su circunstancia que pudiera
parecer una maldición en nuestras
comunidades donde la discapacidad se ve
así de la mayor parte del tiempo para él
ha sido una un motivo de superación para
sus papás ha sido mantenerlo como un
niño que debe vivir la inclusión dentro
de su ambiente
y cuál es la característica que permite
que andy pueda desarrollarse de esta
manera la característica que permite que
lo haga así es la resiliencia
la resiliencia es la capacidad que
tenemos para afrontar con valentía las
situaciones adversas
con optimismo y tomando un aprendizaje
de ellas
quiero preguntarles ahora a cada uno de
ustedes y que levanten su mano quien de
ustedes ha sufrido una situación de
dolor o pérdida a lo largo de su vida
quien han sufrido un momento en el que
ha tenido que levantarse del suelo
sacudirse el polvo y seguir adelante
quiero que sepan que todos y cada uno de
ustedes y yo somos resilientes al igual
que andy a mí me tocó descubrir y
empezar a desarrollar esta capacidad a
edad bien temprana se dice que aún no va
a vivir estadísticamente por lo menos
dos situaciones de duelo profundo en su
vida algunos estos se nos multiplican y
no necesariamente por un nuevo por dos
en mi caso en mi infancia sufrí bullying
en el colegio
posteriormente en mi adolescencia pasé a
formar parte de la población de personas
que tienen un miembro afectado por la
discapacidad mi hermana tuvo un
accidente en el colegio que la dejó en
una silla de ruedas
cuando pensé que ya me había pasado todo
me casé
y con mi esposo tuvimos que hacer frente
al mismo tiempo a problemas económicos a
apoyarle a él en su lucha contra el
alcoholismo y a perder nuestro primer
bebé todo en el mismo año posteriormente
dos embarazos de alto riesgo bebés
prematuros de los cuales uno anda
caminando por aquí
nuevamente pensé que ya había pasado por
todo lo que tenía que pasar en mi cuota
y a mi papi le diagnostican cáncer dos
años con mi papi luchando contra el
cáncer para finalmente triunfar sobre la
enfermedad
mi papi acompañado de todos nosotros
dando su último respiro y entregando su
alma el criador
y como país como estamos porque somos
una comunidad y sus dolores y mis
dolores se comparten
el salvador tiene un puesto 121 de entre
189 países en el índice de desarrollo
humano del pene de eso concluye que el
salvador es un país con mala calidad de
vida
tenemos un número 113 de 144 países en
el ranking de paz global
esto significa que somos un país
peligroso
tenemos un puesto 85 en el doing
bussiness en el índice para de facilidad
para hacer negocios lo cual significa
que el salvador es un país donde todavía
es complicado hacer negocios
y tenemos un puesto 105 en 378 países en
el índice de percepción de corrupción
esto significa que en nuestro país hay
poca o casi nada transparencia
administrativa
todos estos indicadores son tan
negativos como las situaciones de dolor
que nosotros hemos vivido en carácter
individual y entonces qué es lo que esto
ha hecho en el salvador como país bueno
esto ha hecho que nosotros tengamos un
puntaje de 4.37 en una escala del 1 al 5
en el índice de resiliencia del pene ud
se imaginan hasta donde hemos llegado en
esta escala
los jóvenes de entre 15 y 19 años tienen
un 4.44 y aquellos entre 25 y 29 un 4.29
qué quiere decir esto que mientras más
jóvenes más resilientes
y las mujeres aquí todas se van a poner
bien contentas tenemos un promedio de 4
39 sobre 435 de los hombres
y como hemos desarrollado esta capacidad
de resiliencia tanto a nivel personal
como a nivel país
bueno en primer lugar siendo empáticos
la empatía es la capacidad que tenemos
de ponernos en el puesto del otro
reconocer su dolor y hacer algo al
respecto
el salvador se ha caracterizado entonces
por ser empático por darse cuenta cómo
puede hacer para sobrellevar el dolor
con alguien más hay profesiones que por
su naturaleza te provocan ser empático
como la enfermera que vemos aquí sin
embargo hay gente que da un paso más y
aquí quiero que hagan memoria de 'ot' y
bonnie a si se acuerdan hace poco hubo
aquí un accidente de unos buses en santa
anna ella venía de regreso de su trabajo
ya había terminado su jornada ya había
cumplido con sus obligaciones
profesionales sin embargo ella se bajó
del bus y atendió a más de 20 personas
que se habían herido en el accidente y
no sólo eso una madre de familia perdió
su vida en el accidente y su bebé que sí
permaneció con vida y lo tomó se lo
llevó al hospital y hasta que llegó el
resto de su familia a traerlo ella
terminó su misión como enfermera
no es necesario que nosotros estemos en
un accidente de bus para que nosotros
desarrollamos la empatía podemos ser
empáticos cuando vemos necesidades
básicas de otras personas y hacemos algo
al respecto
buscando soluciones
estas niñas viven en garita palmera y
para poder ir a la escuela ellas tienen
que levantarse a las 4 y media de la
mañana tomar esos barquitos y navegar
con pantanos hasta llegar al colegio y
recibir sus clases ellas no se han dado
por vencidas por la situación que han
estado viviendo al contrario han buscado
una solución que probablemente sea
peligrosa pero para poder cumplir sus
sueños y alcanzar sus metas ellas han
buscado la solución de llegar a sus
escuelas en barcos muchos de nosotros no
necesitamos llegar en barcos al colegio
a la universidad sin embargo en más de
alguna ocasión nos ha tocado a pensar
afuera de la caja y ver cómo resolvemos
algún problema que se nos presente en el
trabajo en la universidad hemos buscado
soluciones
reconstruyendo somos un país en el cual
las catástrofes naturales pasan seguidos
hemos sufrido guerra civil inundaciones
terremotos de la ves sin embargo siempre
hemos reconstruido a nuestro país
o tenemos ese espíritu de salida
adelante a pesar de todo si se acuerdan
hace poco un terremoto en la madrugada
que creo que nos despertó a todos y a
pesar de eso a las 6 de la mañana todos
estábamos ya arreglando nos vistiéndonos
y cada quien iba para su trabajo para la
universidad a nosotros no nos detienen
este tipo de cosas entonces la
reconstrucción no sólo es en
infraestructura sino que también va al
interior
trascendiendo cuantos de nosotros
sentimos un orgullo gigante cuando vimos
a estos tres deportistas obtener estas
medallas de oro en los juegos
panamericanos porque porque el salvador
no destaca por ser un país que tenga una
infraestructura deportiva adecuada sin
embargo si ustedes se ponen a ver
siempre hemos participado en eventos de
esta magnitud y siempre ha habido algún
salvadoreño sobresaliente
para trascender no necesitamos ir a un
juego panamericano en el momento en que
yo tomo mi trabajo mis estudios y todas
mis responsabilidades como madres padres
de familias hijos con excelencia en ese
momento yo estoy trascendiendo
ayudando a los demás
este quizás es uno de los que más toca
mi corazón porque como les comenté
nosotros sufrimos un accidente mi
hermana sufre un accidente que la dejó
en una silla de ruedas cuando nosotros
éramos adolescentes y fue hasta entonces
que nosotros nos dimos cuenta de la
necesidad que había entre las personas
con discapacidad y fue hasta entonces
que nosotros pudimos hacer algo al
respecto porque desconocíamos esta
situación entonces nosotros tomamos esa
experiencia que vivimos ese dolor y todo
eso que vimos que existía y lo
proyectamos para ayudar a los demás
creando nuestra fundación y ahora eso
nos ha permitido encontrar el propósito
de nuestro dolor y tocar vidas
positivamente no es necesario que
ustedes creen una fundación para ayudar
a los demás es tan fácil como ayudarle a
alguien a pasar la calle cómo es cómo
ayudarle a alguien a llevar las bolsas
del súper como
ser obedientes porque en eso están
ayudando a sus papás también
todo es cuestión de perspectiva si yo
tomo mi dolor mi situación adversa y la
pongo al servicio de los demás
yo estoy convirtiendo esta situación de
desventaja en una oportunidad de
crecimiento
ante circunstancias difíciles podemos
tomar cualquiera de tres actitudes o
dejamos que nos marque positiva o
negativamente o dejamos que nos destruya
o dejamos que nos fortalezca mi
invitación ahora es para que ustedes
traigan la memoria a sus situaciones
difíciles sus momentos adversos sus
dificultades y las conviertan en algo
que los fortalece las conviertan en algo
que puedan poner al servicio de los
demás
quiero que ahora se acuerden de este
momento de duelo que ustedes vivieron y
ahora quiero que se acuerden de cómo
hicieron para levantarse de ese momento
de duelo
quiero que se acuerden de ese momento
difícil que vivieron y que fue lo que
ustedes hicieron para salir adelante de
ese momento difícil
esa es la resiliencia
en el salvador nuestras situaciones
adversas nos han obligado positivamente
a tener indicadores que también son muy
alentadores
somos el puesto 40 entre 164 países en
el ranking de países más felices del
mundo no les parece contradictorio que
el país que ha sido nombrado muchas
veces como el país más violento del
mundo es el país más feliz del mundo y
eso no es porque el ranking no mide en
base a que no hayan problemas el ranking
mide en base a que la comunidad se
siente apoyada por sus pares para salir
adelante de los problemas y las
desventajas
nos encontramos entre los 15 países más
generosos de latinoamerica
y estamos entre los primeros 10 países
más optimistas de latinoamerica
entonces es el momento de darnos cuenta
que no todo es negativo si tenemos
indicadores negativos pero la ventaja de
esto es que hay mucho por hacer para
darle vuelta a esos indicadores
negativos y convertirlos en algo
positivo
y que depende de la fuerza y la
resiliencia de cada uno de nosotros
poder llevarlo a cabo porque ya cada uno
en su en su vivencia personal ha tenido
que superar obstáculos
el dolor y la adversidad no debe
desperdiciarse solo aprendimos nosotros
cuando mi hermana tuvo el accidente no
debemos desperdiciar el dolor debemos
ponerlo al servicio de los demás es la
única manera en que vamos a poder darle
vuelta a nuestras circunstancias y sacar
provecho de lo que estamos viviendo
cuanto que ustedes han sentido orgullo
por este grupo de jugadores
no creen ustedes entonces que el
salvador ha sabido ser resiliente y
darle vuelta a sus circunstancias
mandando a unos pescadores a jugar
fútbol de playa contra personas que se
preparan bajo una infraestructura y
probablemente entrenamientos
completamente distintos a los nuestros
no es eso motivo de orgullo
nuestros niños que van a las olimpiadas
especiales no creen ustedes que son
niños que luchan día a día con sus
circunstancias y sus papás para sacarlos
adelante para verlos destacar en eventos
como estos no son resilientes ellos
también como salvadoreños
no somos resilientes y generosos cuando
nos olvidamos de nosotros y vamos como
este voluntario a méjico a labores de
rescate en el terremoto de mexico cuando
nosotros tenemos una historia de
catástrofes naturales y quizás la ayuda
debería venir para acá
todo es cuestión de perspectiva
trabajemos con lo que tenemos pongamos
al servicio de los demás nuestras
situaciones adversas pongamos al
servicio de los demás nuestro
aprendizaje y entonces vamos a poder
darle a las futuras generaciones el país
que se merecen y no sólo eso vamos a
poder demostrarle al mundo que el
salvador es más que un indicador
económico gracias
[Aplausos]